in real life your physical should be
higher than mine but my defending should
be better than yours
my defending is better than yours in
person what are you talking about oh my
oh my god you're out of your mind bro
what's up guys tyler adams here hey guys
it's the west
mckinney expedience
bro isn't that crazy we finally made it
to the starting eleven
of fifa you can make the lineup because
they're gonna question why you chose
those people of them
you're gonna have the problems with the
guys when this airs why didn't you start
me tyler
are you happy with your new fifa rating
the only reason i'm questioning the
staff
is because i i was a 79 at charlotte and
i moved to juventus i went
down three how's that possible i don't
even care about my shooting style i
don't shoot anyway but the pace
west is the same speed as me has anyone
watched us run everyone would know i'm
faster than him
right now are you serious right now in
real life your physical should be higher
than mine
but my defending should be better than
yours my defending is better than yours
in person what are you talking about oh
my
oh my god you're out of your mind bro
okay let's just start let's think
this is the scene at dignity health
sports park the venue for this game
i'm derek ray do you think soccer in the
us can be as big as
other us sports yeah absolutely i mean i
think as the mls grows
people are just gravitating more and
more to see that like we have a lot of
talent
the biggest advantage that we have is
that we're all young
and we're all you know playing at
really prestigious clubs and so we're
all learning from
best players around the world the factor
of having
you know the world cup beyond home soil
in 2026 is going to have such a huge
influence i mean
we have the confidence in ourselves that
we're going to be able to do something
special
but most importantly we need to focus on
you know 2022 because
the us obviously didn't qualify for the
last world cup people
growing up they want to watch football
basketball baseball
because those are the sports that
everyone has access to so i think
now the platform is growing do you go
for placement or do you go for power
if you were to play five aside with nba
and nfl players who choose them
giannis yeah he's a baller odell beckham
soccer guy he owns someone liverpool but
i don't think he's playing
i'd put him in goalie massive alex
caruso too he likes soccer he's a big
man city fan
larry nance jr oh yeah he's a baller too
oh my god my shooting is so bad in this
game
of course wesley scores
besides me who has the most skills in
the national team
i'm tackling anyone yeah that's very
true as far as like
defending players i guess the hard ones
to defend yet is christian
he's he's a hard guy geo's really
skillful too he's not like in the same
way though you know like he just does
like a lot of chopping and stuff like
that
you're speaking to weston right now no
one even comes close
listen's a multicultural guy he likes to
listen to a lot of different music
we are the champions
this guy he has to be the center of
attention all the time we
have this thing at national team camp
that instead of like getting fined or
anything like that
like we find that it's more embarrassing
to people that if you come late to a
meal or meeting
then you have to tell a story everyone's
finished with dinner ready to go back to
their rooms and like chill
weston's like no guys i got a story and
everyone's like oh no let's go west and
like clapping and stuff like that
and he gets like this huge uh energy
burst from when people are like
oh saying my name like i gotta do it
that gotta be a good story
and the story that he went to tell was
so
cringe and so embarrassing to everyone
that he had to sit down in the middle of
the story and was like all right guys
i can't finish this